الكريم يرفض بشكل قاطع الشروط الامريكيه
لاستئناف المحادثات
قال ان المحادثات ممكنه فقط عندما يغادر
بوتين اوكرانيا وهذا امر مرفوض طبعا
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه مستمره لكن
بالطبع افضل طريقه لتحقيق مصالحنا هي من
خلال الوسائل الدبلوماسيه السلميه
شرط اعتراف امريكيا بالاراضي الجديده
لروسيا
الولايات المتحده لا تعترف حتى الان
بالاراضي الروسيه الجديده وهذا بالطبع
يعقد بشكل كبير البحث عن ارضيه المشتركه
لمحادثات المحتمله لتحقيق اهدافنا كان
الرئيس بوتن ولا يزال منفتحا على
المحادثات مع جميع الاطراف
لوزير الخارج
قال فيها ان الولايات المتحده جعلت من
اوكرانيا تهديدا وجوديا لروسيا وان واشنطن
وحلف شمال الاطلسي متورطاني في هذه الحرب
لانهما يزودان اوكرانيا بالسلاح ويقدمان
لها تدريب العسكري على اراضيها